[Music]
i'm michelle creamer global strategy
lead for cloud for marketing and i'm
here today with Matt Mattias from Google
marketing platform to talk to you about
how Google's ads and cloud products work
together to help you create delightful
customer experiences now before we get
started I'd love to get a sense for who
we have here in the room this morning
how many of you are on data and
analytics teams inside of your companies
and specifically maybe some of you
working on marketing analytics few hands
good and who here is in an IT team
supporting the marketing department
welcome do we have any partners in the
room great
and how about agencies and last but
definitely not least other marketing
technology companies welcome well
there's a broad cross-section of folks
here in the room but one of the things
that we all have in common is that were
also all consumers so I wanted to just
take a minute of time to think about the
challenge that marketing data silos
presents to us in our lives as consumers
and I'd like to start with a real-life
example not too long ago I undertook the
adventure of renovating a hundred plus
year old house here in San Francisco
where I live that is not my house but
that is actually my bathroom and a half
state of demolition which thankfully I
never had to use in quite that level of
exposure well as anyone who's ever done
a renovation knows it involves a lot of
decision making and a lot of picking of
fixtures things that you've never even
heard the names of before can anyone
relate to this experience a few brave
souls in the audience well my project
was was no different and one of the
things that I had to pick as part of
this renovation was the bathroom vanity
that
that goes underneath your sink and so
I've done a little bit of shopping I had
all my measurements in hand and was
ready to go out and see what was
available and I ended up on the website
of a retailer I had shopped with before
and found the exact right size and style
of that vanity purchased it online and
was really excited to go to sleep
knowing I'd check something off of a
very long list but it turns out that
that next day I got a call from the
retailer saying that item actually was
not available and it wouldn't be anytime
soon and to make matters worse an ad for
that very vanity started following me
around the internet I see some chuckles
over here so it sounds like folks can
relate to having had that experience as
you can imagine it was disappointing and
that I wanted to buy that item but it
wasn't available for me to buy well
about a week later I ended up in that
retailers physical store and found a
vanity that I liked just as much and as
I was shopping and checking out I opted
in to their email marketing list but I
started to get emails for bedroom
furniture which was way outside of the
scope of my project in fact if you'd
seen my living conditions at the time
you'd know that that was definitely not
an option and now a year later plus I am
now getting ads for bathroom faucets and
I definitely I'm happy I did the
renovation but not interested in doing
another one any time soon
now this kind of experience is
frustrating and it felt like the brand
wasn't in tuned with my needs and my
experiences I can only imagine what this
could be like in the future if that
brand would consider all of the
interactions I had with them not just in
that moment but in the years prior and
use that understanding to customize the
interactions they were having with me
every step of the way now
I'm not alone in this desire Harvard
Business Review took a look at customer
analytics and found the stakes are high
customers today respond to experiences
that are timely targeted and tailored to
their specific needs and reject those
that aren't I can tell you from personal
experience that it did not take long for
me to unsubscribe from that email list
once I got that first message we also
know that this is having real business
impact in an HP our survey 44% of survey
responses said that the use of customer
analytics generates significant revenue
growth so we know that there is business
impact here and that consumers really
desire this level of customization so
why is this not what our experiences all
the time well the reason is firstly that
all the information that a marketer
would need to be able to tailor the
experience of a consumer is spread
across many different systems within
their organization you can think of my
example where even the inventory system
and the web CMS were not in sync now to
be truly relevant you also need to look
beyond your first party data to third
party data that might be useful in terms
of getting a holistic picture of what's
actually happening things like weather
patterns and economic indicators siloed
data means it's hard to get insights and
it also means that marketing teams have
to start thinking beyond their
particular channels and silos for an
exact for example an a team that focuses
mostly on ads campaigns needs to start
thinking beyond ads data alone now
bringing all of your data together
across these silos is really the first
step in the data journey once that data
is all together in one place
you can transform it to be ready for
analysis analyze it to generate insights
and use those insights across your
organization to create better customer
experiences
this is fundamentally what we set out to
achieve with cloud for marketing
creating solutions to help enterprises
like yours create delightful customer
experiences from your data and marketing
technology now we've had a number of
sessions over the course of this week
but if focused on how to help you get
value out of your first party data with
Google cloud and I will encourage you to
check them out on YouTube we'll put a
list of them at the end of this
presentation as well as to come by our
booth which is in the showcase for the
rest of today I'd also recommend
specifically looking at the da 101
session where we had customer examples
of success stories of creating these
kinds of experiences from brands like
Ulta American Eagle and Colgate for this
session we're going to specifically
focus on how Google marketing platform
and Google cloud can work better
together to help you create great
customer experiences working
collaboratively across our products we
can help you do three things
understand the customer journey predict
marketing outcomes and personalize the
experience at all touch points Google
marketing platform enables you to build
better digital ad campaigns planning
buying measuring and optimizing the
digital ad experience and web experience
all in one place to drive business
growth and Google cloud helps you
supercharge your customer and marketing
data bringing data together across all
touch points not only ads and web data
but also CRM data email data loyalty
data billing data and more and analyzing
that data at scale now I'd like to turn
it over to Matt to talk a little bit
more about Google marketing platform in
detail
thank you so much Michelle and hello
everybody as Michelle mentioned my name
is Matt Matias and I'm a product manager
for Google marketing platform and I'm
thrilled to be here to talk to you all
today about what Google marketing
platform is capable of and how it can
help you and your companies get value
through all of your marketing programs
let's start with an overview of Google
marketing platform at the highest level
the platform is a collection of products
that helps you get much more value out
of your marketing programs let's go
through each of the seven products that
are within as you can see here on screen
we're gonna start with displaying video
360 which is our prior product for
planning and buying your display and
video campaigns and this is actually
true across the entire internet as
there's a large network of sites that
you can target through displaying video
360 search ads 360 works very similarly
except that it's targeting search ads
and search engines that you can run
search ads on and to note this isn't
just including Google's search engine
this is including many of the most
popular search engines across the
Internet
next is Google Analytics 360 Google
Analytics 360 helps you understand how
your customers are engaging with your
websites and your mobile apps it's a
critical set of data to really
understand deeply how your customers are
engaging with your products data studio
is our reporting product that allows you
to pull data in from many different
sources including Google cloud and then
visualize that in interesting ways it
also makes it very easy to share that
data broadly within your organization
and your other teammates that you're
working with optimize 360 helps you run
a be experiments so you can customize
and customize content for different
groups of people and find out which
combination of contents gonna work best
for your customers surveys 360 lets you
do market research at scale if you are
running a new product program or if you
have made any significant changes to
your your company's brand and you want
to measure the impact on customer
perceptions on that survey is 360 allow
very easily do that and finally tag
manager 360 is a tagging product that
helps to automate the process of
updating and launching new tags on your
websites and as what used to take in the
past potentially months to get a tag
deployed now can be automated and
launched in near-real-time
great so now that we've taken a look at
what google marketing platform is all
about on the products within I want to
walk you through a real customer example
of how they got value from Google
marketing platform and for this example
we're going to take a look at sprint a
large telecommunications company
hopefully many of you in the room are
familiar with them sprint just like many
other telecommunications companies they
offer a lot of services and products to
their customers for mobile
communications the switching costs for a
customer to switch from one
telecommunications company to another
are actually very low now so what that
means is companies have to compete very
hard to keep their customers happy and
show the value and so Sprint's marketing
team was challenged with trying to keep
and retain more of their customers so
what they did is they actually they
joined together two of their teams their
analytics team and their marketing team
and had them collaborate to run a
program to try to reduce their churn
rates so what they did is they they took
a look at within all of their data their
analytics data from their website and
their apps what kind of signals could
predict a customer that was likely to
churn and what they found was a couple
factors was it were pretty good
predictors of a customer likely to churn
things like a customer turning off
automatic bill pay or a customer who
stops engaging with their mobile app so
what they did is inside of analytics 360
they created an audience for just users
who met that exact criteria then they
ship that audience over to display in
video 360 where they ran an ad program
targeted just to those users to try to
remind them of the value that Sprint
offers and keep them within their
network and the results you can see on
screen here they had a fantastic 10%
reduction in churn if you think about
just how much cheaper it is to retain an
existing customer than it is to acquire
a new one
this is pretty significant impact so we
just highlighted one of the ways that a
couple products within google marketing
platform can work better together to
drive more value for you
we also have a lot of additional ways
that the products can be combined to
deliver further marketing value for you
and that's why we've built what we call
an integration Center and inside of the
integration Center that's where we're
highlighting a lot of these integrations
and helping you become aware of them and
take advantage and get them set up what
I'm gonna do next is run a live demo and
show you what the integration center
looks like so if we can switch over to
my laptop perfect what you will do is
you'll start by searching for a
marketing go into your favorite search
engine and searching for a marketing
platform take a look down at the search
results and here is the Google marketing
platform great now you come to our
homepage where you can learn all about
Google marketing platform and the
products within and when you're ready to
get started click the blue button to
sign on in this takes you into an
experience we call Google marketing
platform home here you can get Quick
Links into the products within Google
marketing platform that you're using as
well as have access to a series of
functions we built to better tie these
products together right now I'm gonna
demo the integration Center for all of
you once you launch this you're gonna
see a few different sections here
starting with what we call the
integrations gallery and the
integrations gallery is going to show
you all the different possible
integrations that you could create and
then down below we have sections that
will better tailored to you as an
individual user and company that will
show you all the products and
integrations you are working with right
now
let's start by looking at this gallery a
little bit more deeply here you can see
we've highlighted some of our most
popular integrations you can read a
little bit about them click to learn
more or even take action start getting
going with that integration right now
here you can see displaying video 360
along with analytics 360 the very
integration that Sprint
used in their program we also have
various tabs that will list all the
integrations by product and you can see
as you click through we not only list
integrations within google marketing
platform but we also highlight prominent
third-party integrations as well one in
particular I want to highlight here is
inside of analytics it's possible to
link your analytics 360 accounts to a
bigquery and what you can do is you can
actually export all of your analytics
data into bigquery for all of the power
and the rich querying capabilities of
bigquery when you're ready to skip that
setup you simply click the add
integration button it asks you which
website or mobile app you would like to
target now let's go ahead for this demo
we're gonna look at the Google
merchandise store and you simply follow
the prompts to load up the experience
that guides you through creating this
link but you'll see what will load in
just a moment here is a few steps of a
wizard that asks you for a series of
questions for how you want to export the
data out of analytics and into bigquery
one of the first things you're gonna do
is input an ID of your bigquery project
then you select the source analytics
view where the data is going to come out
of there are various alerts that will be
triggered and so you want to pick who's
going to be receiving those and finally
there are a couple of settings that
control how the data is going to flow
across so you would simply read that and
choose the appropriate option for you
and that's it once you've done this
you're now you're now set your data is
going to be exported out of analytics
into bigquery and you'll be able to do
your analysis there well return us back
to the integration Center experience as
I was highlighting a little bit earlier
you can also see the products that
you're using within google marketing
platform as well as the integrations the
product pairs that you're using right
now all of this is interactive you can
click in any part of this so let's click
into the analytics section for example
and we're gonna see a list of all of
your properties that you're working with
and then off to the right is a series of
columns here for each of the products
that you could potentially integrate
with with those properties for this demo
we're going to look for the the Google
merchandise store that's our demo
account that we'd like to showcase and
you're able to see here for our various
Google merchandise store properties the
other products that they're integrated
with so these numbers mean that this
particular property has been integrated
with three times with display and video
360 once with search ads 365 times with
campaign manager and so on if you
realize oh wow some of my properties
haven't been integrated you can simply
high off figure that out really quickly
here and follow the prompts to go ahead
and set up that integration so we've
tried to make the whole integration
center experience both educational to
help you understand what's possible and
then very actionable so you can follow
the links and set these integrations up
for yourself great and with that I'm
going to switch back over to the main
slides
so we showcased a few different
integrations that we offer and there are
plenty more that that are in the
integration center that you can take a
look at I'm gonna highlight a few more
very briefly here for you the first one
is with search ads 360 and analytics 360
it's possible to export your search ads
data out of the product and into
analytics 360 where what you can do is
marry the two datasets together to get
rich insights on how your marketing
campaigns are truly performing within
search ads 360 you get rich data on the
ad campaigns that you're running keyword
level data and bidding data that you're
your selecting for your programs and
then in analytics 360 you'll have rich
data on your websites in your apps which
pages or screens well that your visitors
your customers are going to how long
they're spending if they ultimately
convert when you marry those two data
sets together you get a holistic picture
of your customer journeys and the
performance next we have analytics 360
with display and video 360 is the very
integration that we looked at earlier
with sprint where you create a
high-value audience inside of analytics
and target ads against it inside of
display and video 360 another with
sprint you saw that they had targeted
folks that they thought were about to
churn another common one that you'll see
is customers will identify shopping cart
abandoners people who are about to
purchase a product from you but for some
reason decide to leave their high-value
group that you may want to remarket to
and get them to come back and
potentially as customers and finally we
have analytics 360 and optimized 360
it's also possible to share your
audiences out of analytics 360 into
optimize and then target an a/b
experiment to them this helps you to
really refine the content that you have
on your sites and make sure that you're
offering exactly the right content to
your customers want to see
within google marketing platform we
recognize that there are many teams of
people and lots of individuals who are
going to be working together to
accomplish your marketing goals and so
accordingly we believe that it's
important for us to build strong
collaboration tools and capabilities
into our products and to showcase an
example of that I'm going to show you
two screen captures here of data studio
you're seeing what to people who are
loading up the same report would see on
the left you have a user who's making
edits live to the report and then on the
right the user you'll see is able to see
the updates in near-real-time
as a person a is making those updates
it's also important to highlight that
data studio connects to many cloud data
sources and so there are quite a few
ways to import cloud data into Data
studio and visualize that data in really
interesting ways it's one great example
as to how Google marketing platform and
Google cloud work better together so
with that hopefully you've got a great
overview now of how Google marketing
platform works and a couple of ideas as
to how - your company might be able to
get some value from it and with that I'm
going to turn it back over to Michelle
who is going to walk you through even
more examples as to how these two
product platforms can work better
together
[Applause]
as Matt mentioned when used together
Google marketing platform and Google
cloud enhance each other
you saw how you can export data from
Google marketing platform into Google
cloud with just a couple of clicks and
the same is true for other Google data
sources such as Google ads play store
data YouTube data firebase data and more
once that data is in Google cloud you
can bring it together with other first
party data like data from your CRM
system your e-commerce system or your
billing system and as it this week that
process is also easier because the
bigquery data transfer service has been
extended to third party systems a
hundred plus available just for you all
today once that data is there you can
use bigquery to get insights faster as
well as use Google's powerful machine
learning tools to find hidden insights
that might be there within your first
party data and you can action those
insights by visualizing them back in
data studio as Matt showed as well as
third party tools like looker and
tableau and finally you can action those
insights back into the Google ads
ecosystem through Google marketing
platform and Google Ads using some of
the integrations like the GA 360 and
display video 360 integrations that Matt
discussed as well as use third-party
tools for activation such as send grid
and email to hopefully make that email
experience better than the one I
described in my example as you can see
Google marketing platform and Google
cloud complement each other and Google
cloud also helps you get more value out
of the other marketing tools that you
use now to help you get to that value
quickly we've put together and built out
a set of use cases to help you get
started and you can learn more about any
of these you
cases by stopping by the booth or
sending an email to the email address
that is included at the end of this
presentation so let's take one of those
use cases for starters purchase
prediction this was the thing that was
missing from my renovation story as a
business you want to be able to
accurately predict what is the next
product or service that a customer is
interested in buying so that you can
deliver better experiences than the one
I described now if any team of marketers
wants to do this today they're likely
have to get two to three technical teams
involved to get the data and it might
take a couple of weeks to bring it
together in a format that's useful for
analysis depending on your business by
this time the customer may have moved on
in their decision making and so the
insights you're going to get are going
to be less relevant now we make this
easier through the data imports that I
mentioned as well as through data
cleansing tools like data prep and the
speed and scale of bigquery but make it
faster to get to insights the marketing
teams can actually use and some of the
things that are possible to do within
the Google Ads ecosystem and beyond
include things like finding look-alike
audiences increasing bids on generic
keywords for an item a customer is
likely to buy an understanding site
behavior and customizing the web
experience accordingly and here is what
a high-level architecture looks like for
how you can use Google Ads in Google
Cloud products together to solve for the
use case a purchase prediction now at
this point you may be thinking okay I
get it
customers are asking for personalized
customized experiences and this has real
business impact if we are able to solve
this problem of breaking down these data
silos bringing data together and
analyzing it at scale but I live in a
multi cloud environment and why should I
do this with Google so I want to just
walk through
beloved areas where we're different
specifically for cloud for marketing
first we're a leader in smart analytics
as a service forests are rated Google as
the only leader and their insight
platforms as a service report we're also
building solutions that are specifically
designed to meet marketers needs so an
example are the use cases that I just
walked through as well as making it
easier to use these solutions themselves
through tools like the bigquery data
transfer service as well as things like
allowing a marketer to build machine
learning models using bigquery ml and
doing that right in sequel and while
we're on the topic of ml and AI
Google is a leader in this area we have
over 7,500 projects that are powered by
AI inside of Google including some of
Google's consumer products like search
maps assistant and more and we've
embedded ml and AI into the core of our
solutions in Google cloud to make it
accessible and enable those
transformative experiences so in
addition to the cloud for marketing
specific ways that we're different we
also build on all the ways that Google
cloud itself is different and you've
heard a lot about this over the course
of the week in our keynotes so I won't
go into it in great detail but just to
highlight a few of our strengths here
security fully automated operations and
openness are in our DNA and lastly we
bring the best of Google to solving
marketing use cases things like using
the technology of the Google cloud
vision API to be able to solve for
unstructured data and getting value out
of that visual unstructured data plus
Google teams have years of experience in
working with enterprises of all kinds
across the globe to solve marketing
challenges using cloud and ads
technology this means that Google can
help you really accelerate
your digital transformation so we've
talked a lot about how we're helping
enterprises today by leveraging our
products that are together and I want to
just give you a sense for what we're
building how we're turning that linear
data journey into a flywheel that can
keep pace with customer expectations and
decision making the cloud for marketing
console is our first step in making it
possible for marketers to solve for use
cases in a way that's faster simpler and
smarter and it's available in alpha now
if you're interested in seeing more
about the console and asking questions
in detail you can do that at our booth
and there's product managers and
engineers on site to help answer your
questions within the existing cloud
console we've created this cloud for
marketing console to make it more
engaging and interactive for
non-technical users when a user opens
the console they'll see a dashboard that
will have available data sources based
on the data they've brought into
bigquery as well as built-in tagging and
access controls we have templated
queries that make it easier for you to
do to get value out of your data and
derive insights and predictive models
that help you understand and predict
customer behavior and drive business
outcomes and finally we have links to
the data dashboard data studio
dashboards that Matt described that are
built directly into the tip into the
console as a template we make bringing
your data into bigquery faster by
providing tools that give you the
step-by-step instructions you need
directly in the console and managing all
of your marketing related data is
simpler will be built in tagging and
access controls you can also maintain
data privacy and security down to the
column level for sensitive data
and PII and finally the console provides
smarter insights about your marketing
customers and products by leveraging
templated queries and the same models
that power Google services with no
coding needed now as we build products
like the console to help make it
possible to solve for marketing use
cases faster simpler and smarter we're
also trying to make it easier for
enterprises to get the most value of how
our products work better together as an
example of this we include templated
queries for queries that you might need
to run around Google Analytics or other
web analytics data in the console and we
also have seamless integrations into
data studio built in we're excited to
see what kinds of experiences you all
build by using Google cloud and Google
Ads products effectively better together
and I want to give you a little bit of
inspiration here and bring up one of our
customers Kenny Wu who's vice president
of product at essence to tell you how
he's doing it
hello I'm Kenny I look after the product
team at essence and today I'd like to
talk to you a bit about how we've used
machine learning in Google cloud and
activated that to create better customer
experiences via the Google marketing
platform essence is an advertising
agency part of group M & WPP and we're
focused on creating better experiences
and making better decisions using data
we work with some of the largest
advertisers in the world target
NBCUniversal t-mobile and Google to name
a few today I'll be taking you through
an example of how we customized ad
creative with Google but we do this for
many of our clients across many
industries so first the world right now
is buzzing with talks of artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
science of making things smart and the
science of getting computers to do
something without being programmed with
the rules well there's a lot of theory
that's going on I'd like to share a
concrete example of how we brought this
to life so a few months ago Google
marketing came to us with the challenge
how do we help consumers better
understand the power of Google assistant
specifically this idea of how assistant
can offer helpful information at the
moment when it's relevant so a good
example of this is in the kitchen any
home cooks out there people are
interested yeah so I was making pancakes
other day and for those science geeks
out there we know that you love in this
dough with a bit of soda and a bit of
acid and I was replacing vinegar with
lemon juice but I had my hands covered
in flour and forgot what the conversion
was great moment to find some
information via assistant so what we did
is we took this idea of helping helping
people in the right moments find the
information that they need
specifically around a recipes section in
a partnership with the Guardian what we
looked at specifically was demonstrating
how Google assistant could recommend
relevant recipes based on the recipes
that you're looking at so this idea of
contextual advertising has existed for a
long time but usually you'd actually
don't have that much interesting
information you know a web page where
something is served roughly what the
topic looks like potentially where the
user is located and if you're lucky you
get keyword level information so
something we might have considered with
just that information is to do some text
categorization let's categorize sweet
keywords and savory ones and then
recommend an accompany recipe that would
be relevant to something sweet or
something savory however you could end
up with some weird results pancakes
which for me is a sweet breakfast food
can also mean kimchi pancakes and a
recommendation for something like orange
infused maple syrup would not be very
appropriate so we took a look at the
other information that we had at hand
which was the pictures of the recipes
themselves and took a look at how we
could take this content to customize our
messaging we used auto ml and cloud and
the specifically vision to train a model
on identifying sweet and savory foods
using the imagery alone so without text
analysis it took a little time about 200
images that needs to be hand categorized
into sweet and savory but afterwards
we're very accurately able to predict
whether or not something was sweet or
savory that allowed us to come up with
much more contextually relevant
messaging without the weirdness of
kimchi pancakes and maple syrup so
putting this all together with text
analysis and image analysis we're able
to create ads that appeared customized
and conversational with just content and
context this can then be extended in the
future by bringing in the first party
and third party data that was mention
and earlier I would create even better
ads well this feels great having ads
that make sense that are relevant to the
content that's next to you it has a big
business impact as well we're able to
create thousands of ads in a matter of
hours across each individual recipe page
we also applied similar methodology on
things like movie reviews restaurant
reviews travel to name a few and we saw
a major lift in response based on the
more relevant ads in fact we saw a nine
point five percent lift in category
understanding and this is interesting
because that means that one in ten
people who saw these ads versus the
control had a much better understanding
of what Google assistant can do for them
on a day-by-day basis so how do we do
this
so here's the technical architecture
behind all this
what we did is on a twice daily basis
collect information from The Guardian
and a JSON file about all the news news
articles recipe articles reviews etc
that were published and we analyzed that
information in Google Cloud first off we
look took a look at the content every
brand is different so some brands want
to appear next to a large swath of
content some very narrow so we actually
trained an auto ml natural language from
natural language processing model to
determine whether or not the content was
appropriate for that brand second we use
the natural language API to extract
salient keywords such as in the last
example I think ginger here a salient
keyword from the text in the recipe
further we use the visual analysis as I
mentioned before to determine sweet and
savory finally we took a look at
additional data we could use to bring in
and enrich the information that we had
already a good example of this is Maps
data that we used around
front reviews given that the Guardian is
focused very much in the UK we looked at
where a person's location was and
whether or not the restaurant was within
the city at which point we would
recommend a restaurant in a particular
neighborhood or if is outside of the
city and we would indicate which town it
was in all this combined together
allowed us to construct customized copy
that was then fed and activated in the
Google marketing platform so the two
pieces of the marketing platform that we
use studio where we created the dynamic
ads combined the customized text with
the ad imagery and then we serve those
ads via Google marketing platforms TV
360 with a special connection with the
Guardian were able to determine which
pages would be served as we were buying
buying impressions through DV 360 so
therefore we could customize the content
that would show up so I hope that this
short example inspires you to take a
close look at the data that you have on
hand not just the data that you might be
using today to create better experiences
and make better decisions for your
customers your clients and your team
Thanks
thank you so much Kenny you've managed
to figure out how to make this entire
room even hungrier when were the only
things probably standing between you all
in lunch but it was very inspiring so if
you are interested in what you heard
today around building better customer
experiences using your data and
marketing technology you can learn more
about this by checking out all of the
other sessions that will be posted on
YouTube for this event and these are the
titles here as well as visit us and the
booth and we're interested to hear from
you so you can reach our team via the
email address on screen thank you so
much for being here and then feedback as
a gift so please before you leave don't
forget to rate this session and tell us
what resonated with you and what you'd
love to hear more of thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]